so tell me about how you because I'm
curious about just getting the arc here
I know that you the ark I'm trying to
that's what I I know I like trying to
find because you're doing a timeline I
know where you okay I understand where
you come from and better than most and
there's a
I understand that Irish Catholic thing
is so funny that when you said that you
were chewing gum my mom who's a
wonderful woman a great mom but she had
this almost Victorian Irish Catholic uh
division when it came to the boys and
the girls so she had this thing where my
my brothers and I could up in any
way and she'd be like oh those boys and
if uh if one of my sisters chewed gum
yeah she was like your dad come out
you know what you look like a trap
and we'd be in the corner I'd have like
nine sticks of gum in my mouth yeah she
wouldn't say anything to me no she'd say
oh he's a good little boy let's hope
that hair changes color
and then she'd whip around and one of
you know my nice sisters would come in
and go hello Mother you yeah spit that
out I remember I wanted to get my ears
pierced and my parents were like you're
gonna look like a pirate
I don't think that's true no and also
we're talking about like the 70s for me
and like 80s for you and it's just like
this I don't know it's this crazy time I
think it's just how some fat my family
was like that they let Danny get away
with anything and then with me it was
totally different sweaters are different
in Armenian culture it's I guess it's
the same thing which is Danny's the boy
so he can do whatever he wants yeah but
I didn't know Irish families were like
that too right but oh my God yeah my
uncle my mom is one of seven there's six
girls and a boy my uncle who I love love
you Uncle Ricky
um who I think's Matt Conan
um he but he like got kicked out of
schools and kicked out of high school
and he's on the hockey team he's lost
all his front teeth like he's like you
know plays a super ultra fun like went
to Harvard like dude no one cares like
you just get away with whatever they
want yeah yeah like yeah it's the way it
should be
it's the way it should be yeah I I think
so I think it builds characters well we
were complaining about it you were
saying that's how we should I know and
then I realized why am I sticking up for
my sister's four I love that guy deserve
it but like girls always had to I always
felt like the girls had to work like
twice as hard hard you know yeah like
yeah and also I think about the picture
of me and my little virginal white you
know first communion dress and it's like
that's how they want to picture you all
the time when you're little I wore the
same dress at my community
I'm wondering what that was all about uh
I remember being scared of communion you
know women or confession confession was
terrifying yeah confession is terrifying
because you'd go in there and I would
always freeze up and just make up things
because I'm not going to say what I'm
really doing I would no kid says what
they're really no no kid says you don't
go in there and go like well anyway I
touched myself you don't say that to a
priest no
but you know it's so weird like you
don't see the priest there's just like
this silhouette but you lie don't you
feel guilty lies and I lied and then you
get forgiven so it doesn't
matter
is that how you ended every confession
and then something else and then hey it
doesn't matter anyway
that's it Padre Chomp Chomp my dear are
you chewing gum you're so bad
I'm chewing gum I remember going sitting
in the Pew and going this I was in high
school and our friend his name is Gordy
he goes in and you know we all would
make a pack like I mean you're not gonna
tell them this this I'm gonna tell him
we're having you know sex or anything
and it's like no of course not so it's
like yeah like you go and you'd be like
I you know I took the lord's name in
vain and I fought with my parents and I
lied and I cheated on math that's
whatever and then you know and you just
kind of like finally like five Hail
Marys okay great right that was very
typically how it went so Gordy's in
there and all of a sudden we hear like
the priests kind of start like raising
his voice which never happens right
and then Gordy kind of comes out bright
red won't look Us in the eye like goes
up to the front kneels down and start
doing what you know it's normally five
Hail Marys so we're all like what the
heck just happened with Hardy you know
so we go in I go into this and then we
all we've all gone we've all gone up
we've all done our prayers our little
Penance we're all standing out front for
like half an hour it's getting dark
Gordy's still up there
and to this day I still am like you
don't know what the hell did he tell but
he had to say like 700 000 helmets like
like I like I would think it was like
you're you might go to hell for this oh
my God
I don't know we gotta find out we're
gonna get some people
Gordy and Pittsfield whatever Gordy said
you know what's crazy when you think
about it now it's such a weird thing we
all just accepted that you say to the
priest I did this I stole you know I ate
a piece of chocolate cake when I wasn't
supposed to I took the extra Pop-Tart I
used the lord's name in vain and then
it's like going to an auto body guy and
he gives you an estimate yeah he's like
right off the top of his head that six
Hail Marys three our fathers maybe do a
rosary do a rose you know whatever and
you just like like he he can hear it
like one of those people that can guess
your weight yeah 162. wow you nailed it
and if you get a second opinion it's
probably like fewer Hail Mary you know
what they should have had is another
confessional where you could say you
know what let me let me get another rate
I'm gonna get another one
but I really did I lied and just would
say things like I and and they were
almost biblical I and I envied I I
coveted it my neighbor's wife something
it's like how old are you 11.
I left with the Sheep you did what I
told biblical nonsense
I know